this is your first return since the
Vampire Diaries I mean this is sort of
your heart and soul so what can fans
expect and what does it feel to finally
accomplish this you know just saying one
of what in one of my producing partners
is here and we were just talking last
night there's still so many elements to
layer in and we've still got like a
couple of hundred effect shots that need
to be sort of dropped in but that shows
delivery which is the bulk of it right
so it's the last eleven months of our
lives have been constructing every frame
with this incredible team to get this to
where it is but at great cost to our
lives and health and and families and
stuff and so that's the passion of that
need to create something that an
audience you know if someone's gonna
spend 40 minutes of their life right yes
I get life is long but our attention
spans and our bandwidth is so limited
because there's so much happening if
someone's gonna give us a few hours of
their life I want to make it as
impactful as possible and season ones of
shows bottom line let's just get that on
the open they're tough because you're
trying to build a world you're trying to
find your footing now in a network
scenario you've got a long runway 22
episodes so so you can falter in places
and really find your footing in this
you've got ten episodes and there are no
commercial breaks there's no 6x story
structure you're just in it so you've
got to find a fluidity to it even with
different directors and different you
know story aspects and that's what we
you know that's the beauty of working
with Netflix is they allowed us to do
that Netflix 90w allowed us to keep
going to really nurture and find these
creatures and make them as scary as
possible but it's grounded and so we're
Vampire Diaries was sort of sci-fi
fantasy this is a very grounded
hard-hitting version and that's what I
loved about this show it was about you
know look after all those years of
playing Damon who is snarky and funny
and sexy I just wanted to play a
character who was just a good normal man
mm-hmm his superpower was just being a
great dad or being a great scientist you
know and that's
I just craved that but we found out one
interesting thing is that people don't
want an extraordinary hero they want an
extraordinary hero and so between
Michael Fane and Damon I mean and uh
Luther Swan we really got to reconfigure
sending them down a really intense
amazing path and you mentioned too early
to on your Instagram that you went to
the hospital can you tell us about that
what happened well you know look we all
push ourselves we all work really hard
and sometimes your body you can only
take so much and that's the sort of
passion of pushing yourself in any space
whether you're in banking whether you're
in filmmaking that's when you know you
really love something yeah is when
you're when you when you take a quick
break in the ER from exhaustion it's
that simple
you know but for me I'm a father now and
once you become a parent your sole
purpose in life is to stay alive and
healthy and so I go to great lengths to
make those to make that happen and if
anything it makes for a great story
which is I you know love this show so
much and push so hard for it by the way
I just read this insane article so
countries that that participate in
daylight savings time I'm gonna get the
numbers wrong so when you spring forward
we lose an hour right we get more
daylight but we lose an hour or do we
gain an hour no I think we lose an hour
when society loses an hour
heart attacks go up 26 percent or 23
percent increase in heart attacks when
you fall back and you gain that hour
again they see like a 26 percent
decrease in heart attacks in society
how crazy is that crazy at one hour
makes a difference of sleep or
relaxation to the human body so you know
it really lends its the fragility of
this thing this little thing that we're
all walking around and you've got to
take care of it
migraine I just had a son recently well
two years ago so it cannot change thank
you changes your life and perspective
and and you now see you executive
producer you started the film you
directed you do anything else for you
like grip or anything but like balance
all those roles and what is the
advantage of being a director as well as
an actor you know by the way the skill
sets that I acquired from vampire
diaries were immeasurably important in
this allowed me to come in and do this
and I have the most amazing partners one
of my producing partners is here with me
um we do and go everywhere together now
because there's just such an immense
amount of work always when you're being
a director when you're acting or you're
an actor that is a director you speak
the exact same language as those people
on the screen they push you and you push
them to a place because there's such a
mutual respect that you can push them as
hard as you can and they can push back
in the perspective they're gonna be
pushing back from you get it so there's
this amazing sort of dance that's really
really wonderful and you can fight for
them especially not just on on set but
in the Edit but what people don't think
about is is that it's not just about
getting this on screen you know we've
been in post-production on the show for
11 months so my partners and I I mean we
have been every day all day of our lives
with this major huge team of people
putting this together focused on this
thing all day long I mean it's an it's
an it's an immeasurable amount of work I
think of every I think if people knew
the amount of ATP production that it
takes to produce even a 35 or 40 or 50
minute episode
television they'd be a lot kinder in
there I was just thinking that people
don't realize how much work and effort
goes into it so I guess it in the sense
that you put that on social media
letting people know through this journey
that you actually went to the hospital I
mean you you're giving your life to this
project which is yeah and that's why I
hope it resonates with people I mean the
thing is is again you know I say this
season Ones of shows they're difficult
you're building out the world you're
finding your footing and what I say to
people in Netflix will probably slap me
on the hand or the face I'm not sure but
if you were a fan of The Vampire Diaries
or just a fan of this genre you don't
know me but if you're a fan of The
Vampire Diaries and you liked whatever I
did for years give this show a chance
and if you don't like it just let it
keep going on your TV because I want
Netflix to know people are watching this
because once we get into a season 2
scenario we really now we've found our
footing and the world has changed
drastically from where you saw first see
Luther Swan in the first episode the
social relevance and the factors that we
get to explode in this world look I come
from television I've never been on a
show that wasn't a water-cooler show
even my first little show is called
young Americans many years ago but lost
and vampire diaries were big tentpole
water-cooler shows for a long time that
level of storytelling and that level of
intricacy built into the viewership and
to the audience we want to create
characters that you have to how you'll
have a hard time the inner inner
conflict that you have with you love
this person you hate this person are
they making the right decision why are
they doing that I want to get under your
skin I want to get under your
fingernails I want you to feel what we
are trying to tell it's not from our
point of view who cares about my point
of view it's the things that are
happening in the world that we're
dealing with in society you and I and
everyone in this room that are happening
in this show borders racism
medicine fear politics the fear of
politics all of these things that are
hitting us and not just in our own echo
chambers I mean globally we get to put
into this show and weave it into the
thread of the text the fabric of the
story but without bludgeoning people
over the head with our point of view
because again who can't say that who in
the hell cares about my point of view I
want to tell great stories and great
characters and if you think about film
you know film is 30 percent character 70
percent plot television 70 percent
character 30 percent plot you've got to
build these characters that people are
gonna want to go season after season
after season and Luther Swan you know
once you start sort of start peering
behind the curtains and peeling back the
layers of the onion you're gonna start
to see a very complicated man who is put
into a situation where he's in the fight
of his life trying to save humanity
protect his child and and stay alive so
I'm excited for that but I'm very
excited to just hear what people have to
say and I'm very excited to get into
really blowing the lid off of this and
opening this world up in season two and
then some you know for sure
you